in the heart of ayothaya
special prayers for a temple to the
Hindu god Rama it's an issue that
resonates strongly in kar sevak purim a
complex that our right-wing Hindu group
runs this was one of the places where
crowds gathered in 1992 galvanized by
leaders from India's Hindu nationalist
BJP party they believed the nearby 16th
century Babri mosque was built by a
Mughal Emperor after destroying a temple
on the exact spot where God Rama was
allegedly born on December 6 frenzied
mobs tore down the boss sparking deadly
riots and driving a wedge between Hindus
and Muslims among the mobs was Hanuman
yada today he sells books on Hinduism
he remains unapologetic about his role
in violence the demolition of the Babri
mosque washed away the stain that the
Muslim rulers left on India they were
Outsiders invaders it was the right
thing to do welcome Yaakov also works as
a guide taking visitors around kar sevak
forum which has been preparing for years
to build a grand Ram temple on the
contested site the place has long been a
pilgrimage site for Hindus from across
India victory to Lord Rama the Trent
we've worked for so long towards our
goal of building a Ram temple it's not
just me but all the Hindus of this
country feel deep down in their souls
that the Ram temple should be built here
this is a question of our faith with
India's Supreme Court now eating those
goals security has been beefed up to
ensure there is no backlash memories of
the violence are still strong among yo
Thea's small Muslim population the riots
nearly three decades ago killed at least
16 people here and it wasn't limited to
the town the destruction of the Babri
must have sparked some of the most
intense violence here in Mumbai more
than 900 people the majority the Muslim
were killed in riots that erupted
across India's commercial capital areas
like these in northern Mumbai saw some
of the worst violence Rasheeda quote
Ivana is from the Bora Muslim community
she lost her husband and her
brother-in-law in the riots they tried
to rescue a sister from a neighborhood
hit by violence they never returned we
couldn't understand what was happening
everyone said it was because of IO Tia I
went to police stations and hospitals
every day to look for my husband I was
afraid I would find his belongings but I
never did later discovered that
Rashida's husband shibir had been burned
alive by a mob though she'd receive
compensation from the government the
case was never investigated back in
ayutthaya social activist gofrance
Siddiqui runs a group that aims to
bridge differences between young Hindus
and Muslims through discussions and
dialogue the participants weren't even
born when the violence marked the town
they're eager to move on from the past
whether you build a temple or a mosque
the conflict will never end
instead put a social institution on the
disputed land we don't want either a
temple or a mosque we need better
education and jobs we need companies to
invest here we want decent Moors instead
a util will get its long-cherished Ram
temple the hope is that this will
finally help close India's deepening
religious fissures and bring peace for
more on this DW correspondent Sonia
fauna card is now from the Indian
capital Delhi so Sonia we're hearing
that Prime Minister Narendra Modi
addressed the nation following this
verdict what has he been saying that's
right I mean in a live televised address
Prime Minister Narendra Modi called
today a historic day he heard how hailed
this verdict by the Supreme Court he
said it was a golden chapter in the
history of the Indian judiciary and
interestingly Prime Minister Modi also
drew a parallel between this verdict and
the fall of the Berlin Wall
he
you know November 9th is the date when
the Berlin Wall fell and to communities
reuniting people of two communities and
he says this date you know gives us a
lesson to move forward together well
alright despite the hopes that this
decision is going to bring peace
security has been tightened in India
what are the fears of a backlash that's
right I mean we've seen massive security
arrangements in place today in India and
not just in the northern state of Uttar
Pradesh where that the town of Ionia is
located but literally across India
across many many Indian states in utter
Pradesh thousands of extra troops have
been deployed today that is in addition
to local police who have been trained to
contain riots the police they are also
very carefully monitoring social media
in a bid to quash rumors or any
inflammatory posts and they're also very
wary of you know triumphant celebrations
by Hindu groups or hearing reports that
an iota has some residence you know
bursts firecrackers and distributed
sweets when the verdict came out but
they were persuaded to go back by the
police and the background told this of
course is that the authorities are
trying very hard to avoid a repeat of
the kind of violence that we saw in 1992
in the aftermath of the demolition of
the 16th century Babri Masjid bye-bye
Hindu mobs and if you remember that
sparked deadly riots across India
killing more than 2,000 people
well Sonia this ruling of course in
favor of the Hindus comes at a time when
there's a Hindu nationalist government
in power
how do minorities feel about all of this
well you know the building of the Rama
temple has really long been a rallying
point for the Hindu nationalist BJP
party you know in the 1980s and the
1980s and the 90s the the BJP really
spearheaded a political campaign on the
plank of building around temple at the
disputed site you know this eventually
led to the culmination of that violence
and the demolition of the mosque and
ever since the media peace has come to
power we have seen repeated calls to
build a temple from members of the beach
at the same time we have to remember
that some members of the BJP are
currently facing trial for their
involvement in the violence of 1992-93
so against that backdrop I think it's
fair to say that though many Muslim
groups do they have accepted this
verdict there is a sense of unease and
disquiet in the community Muslims
feeling very insecure especially since
the BJP came to power where you know
religious and social tensions have
really deepened under this government
all right GW correspondents on your
phone Nagar reporting from Delhi thank
you